-"T'es bath, t'es in",
c'est le groupe Ottawan qui
l'a repris dans un succès mondial.
...
-T'ES OK ! T'ES BATH !
T'ES IN !
YOU'RE OK !
YOU'RE SMART !
YOU'RE IN !
-J'ai besoin de tendresse.
J'ai tellement de problèmes.
Donne-moi ton adresse.
Je veux quelqu'un qui m'aime.
-T'AS BESOIN DE TENDRESSE.
T'AS TELLEMENT DE PROBLEMES.
SUPPORTE TA JEUNESSE
ET VIENS BOIRE UN CAFE CREME.
T'ES OK ! T'ES BATH !
T'ES IN !
YOU'RE OK !
YOU'RE SMART !
YOU'RE IN !
[Elle chante en anglais.]
[...]
-Tu peux m'appeler après
après 8h, au 310 24 32.
On pourra si tu veux
aller au ciné.
Et si t'es pas fatigué,
ensuite on ira partager
le meilleur strawberry sundae
des Champs-Elysées.
-T'ES OK ! T'ES BATH !
T'ES IN !
YOU'RE OK !
YOU'RE SMART !
YOU'RE IN !
-La vie est plus facile
quand on la vit à deux.
Le bonheur est moins fragile
quand on est amoureux.
-LA VIE EST PLUS FACILE
QUAND ON LA VIT A DEUX.
MAIS UN JOUR UNE FILLE
TE RENDRA MALHEUREUX.
T'ES OK !
T'ES BATH !
T'ES IN !
YOU'RE OK !
YOU'RE SMART !
YOU'RE IN !
T'ES OK !
T'ES BATH !
T'ES IN !
[Elle chante en anglais.]
[...]
-Au lieu de rester là
à philosopher,
vient plutôt danser,
vient plutôt chanter.
-T'ES OK !
T'ES BATH !
T'ES IN !
...